Columbia asks any thoughts on bringing
relevance to the funeral business
industry tell me a great question this
was a fun one India your dark so was
pwned for this question I assume you're
talking the funeral home business
ironically I've addressed this in other
places either in a blog post or in a
public speech or I've it's an industry
I'm fascinated by I once gave the
recommendation of somebody in the
funeral business to become the number
one flour content site on the internet
because that was the connection to
something positive that I could make and
it was a really really an interesting
you know back to everybody's a media
company you guys have heard my spiel on
this if you haven't google it around I
think companies should become media
companies and playing sections that are
related to their industry not
necessarily if you're a funeral home you
can't start out reviewing other funeral
homes business you have vested interests
but something like flowers is an
interesting gateway to that business you
know look I'm gonna use your question as
it ended which is innovation is what
awakes sleepy gray-haired industries
right I came along in the wine world
that was a very pretentious very this
very looked down on very gray-haired
wine experts were 60 year old dudes they
definitely weren't 25 year old jet fans
from Jersey and so I came in there and I
innovated first it was launching a
dot-com site in 1996 later it was doing
a YouTube show less than a year after
YouTube came out around the subject the
way you you you you wake up an industry
is by innovating you know looking at
things like snapchat looking at things
like smart technology and augmented
reality and Pinterest and and things of
that nature and so obviously it sounds
like you're in a very sensitive space
you've got to be careful
obviously death is at the height of
emotion in our society one thing up it's
been spending a lot of weird Zen time on
is that we don't know how to die
gracefully in America we you know like
I'm very fascinated by that meaning we
fight and like medicine ourselves up so
intensely I'm getting in a little bit of
tangent but I get it because boy in out
of all the passions I have the number
one core passion I have is I do not want
die and it is not even a remotely close
second
[ __ ] the Jets and everything else like
that is my number one passion and so I
get it so I would say navigate carefully
based on the question but to go on a
higher level of waking up a gray-haired
industry disrespect the gray-haired
industry understand your history
understand it but don't respect it to a
fault get it oh crap wait subscribe I
need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in social so
subscribe